>> I'm Nancy Knowlton, the CEO of Smart Technologies
and I believe role models are incredibly important
for particularly women here in the Middle
East. I think that it's challenging enough
for people, young people to figure out a career
today, but maybe more so for young women where
they haven't had such strong participation,
particularly in business or perhaps science.
So seeing successful women and having those
women share what has been their key to success
I think will be very important for young women
as they chart their course. And if you look
at the number of young people, particularly
in the region, the percentage of those young
people who are women, it's very important
to engage them, to show them that they've
got a role to play and exactly what that role
could be. I think back to my own time when
I was graduating from university, there were
very few female role models and I really had
to chart my own course and so today I'm very
generous with my time and sharing incites
and whatever I can with young women so they
get the sense of whatever they can dream is
in fact possible.